we are used to seeing unfortunately very
emotional scenes after school shootings
across this country but a dramatic
confrontation at a Wisconsin high school
ended without any loss of life a 17 year
old teenager was shot and wounded by
police after they say he threatened an
officer with a gun Dean Reynolds is at
Waukesha South High School that's near
Milwaukee good morning to you Dean how
did school officials discover the
student even had a gun good morning well
they found out about it when a fellow
student alerted school officials that he
had seen the weapon and now officials
are crediting him with possibly
preventing a greater tragedy students
reunited with loved ones Monday morning
after police say a 17 year old classmate
at Waukesha South High School was seen
with a handgun he was reported at
another significance whoever gun on a
local affiliate spoke off-camera with
the mother of the boy who reported
seeing the weapon the person with the
gun was in the class with him and he
snuck out of the class and told you know
some officials where he was what class
he was in and what Sutan had a gun the
school resource officer immediately
responded to the classroom the SRO
school resource officer made efforts to
secure the classroom by getting the
other students to safety police officers
who responded to the classroom attempted
to convince the student to drop his
weapon
the suspect removed the handgun from his
waistband and pointed it at the officers
an officer was forced to discharge his
firearm striking the suspect students on
campus reported hearing two or three
gunshots the school was immediately put
on lockdown and later evacuated I like
was like scared for my life because I
didn't know where he was officers
treated the suspect who was taken to a
hospital in stable condition
I just am very thankful that we were in
a situation where only one person was
injured and there we aren't in a
situation that could have been much much
worse now the officer who shot the
suspect is an 11 year veteran of the
and the police chief here says his
actions were in line with department
policy
Anthony Dean thank you